For experts in emotion interview.
We have the honor of speaking with
Dr Leah Summerville on emotion and
adolescence.
So doctor Somerville is an assistant
professor of psychology at Harvard
University.
She received her phd from Dartmouth
College where she examined how individual
differences and anxiety influenced the
physiological and neural processing of
threatening and unpredictable information.
She then completed her post doctoral
training at the Sackler institute for
Developmental Psychology,
psycho biology,
Athey Weill Cornell medical
college currently work in
the affect of neuroscience
and development lab,
which she directs is focused on unique
relationships between brain development
and everyday behavior as both are
changing during the adolescent years,
heavily influenced by her experiences
working in the team crisis center.
A longterm objective of her lab is
to inform a potential linkage between
adolescent specific emotional changes,
brain functioning,
and the tendency for psychiatric illness
and sub optimal decisions to emerge
during the second decade of life.
She's also teaming up with Boston area
middle schools and high schools to
conduct outreach activities,
focused on getting adolescents excited
about science and most notably,
Dr Somerville's first job was as a
waitress in a greasy spoon diner.
So with that,
I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview with doctor Leah Summerville.
So welcome Leah. Thanks for
speaking that. That's today.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
What I wanted to start out with asking
you about is a little about your journey
into the world of emotion.
So what first kind of sparked your
attention and got you interested in this
topic?
Sure.
Um,
well I got interested in emotion I think
right at the beginning of my college
years. Um, I thought that um,
I would probably end up as a psych
major even going into college. Um,
but when I wanted to really
gain was experienced working
in laboratory settings.
Um, so I ended up working in two different
labs, um, early on in my college years,
both of which approached the study
of emotion in very different ways.
So I worked in one lab that was looking
at cognitive biases and clinical
depression. So looking at, um,
emotional sort of processes
from a clinical perspective.
And then on the other end I was working
as well in a neuroscience lab that was
trying to really pinpoint the role
of a subcortical part of the brain,
the Amygdala in sort of detecting and
assigning relevance to cues in the
environment.
So these two research experiences,
although they were really different,
um,
sort of had a common
thread of emotion in them.
And I think that it kind of hooked me.
And then I went to,
there was no turning back from there.
So now you're hooked and stuck forever.
I think so.
So I wanted to ask you a little bit about,
since you've been hooked,
kind of what you've been
doing research wise,
I'm cause you're doing some
really exciting work. Um,
so one of the questions I wanted
to ask you about is, I mean,
you've really conducted fascinating
research using these tools of neuroscience
to better understand the way that the
brain develops and shapes our emotional
experiences sort of from
childhood into adulthood.
And I'd love to hear your perspective
on what you think some of the most
interesting and exciting
discoveries are here.
Sure. Um, I think the,
the main discovery that I am very excited
to have had a chance to work on is not
necessarily my own,
but when that's been sort of developing
and changing over the last, let's say,
decade,
um,
which is the idea that part of the reason
why adolescents may behave in unique
ways in terms of their emotional lives
and experiences may in fact be due to the
way that in part by two the way
that the brain develops. So, um,
typically adolescents are thought of
as having a sort of unique profile of
emotional experiences. So one could say
that they're oriented toward rewards,
which leads them to take risks.
Um,
people could consider them as moody
or more volatile in their emotional
reactions. And there is some data
supporting this characterization. Um,
however,
people have used in classically
used these characterizations as,
as things some sort of negative
and um, almost, you know,
unfortunate things about adolescence.
Um,
some people have characterized them as
being in a state of temporary insanity or
that they're unable to control themselves
and seeing things along those lines.
Um,
however,
in the last 10 years I brain imaging
has allowed us to pinpoint that in fact,
um,
trajectories and ways in which the brain
develops during the second decade of
life may in fact lead adolescents to
be more susceptible to the influence of
emotion on their day to day behavior.
And this,
and this might change or reframe the way
we can think about adolescence as a way
from a sort of deficient period of the
lifespan in toward thinking of this as a
very normative and almost sort of mediated
by developed by typical developmental
trajectories of the brain.
So right, so you study this
at this period of adolescence,
which is such a unique and
memorable time in everyone's life,
but at the same hand on the same hand,
like what you're saying is it's described
as this period people say of like
storm and stress, right? With all
gas and no breaks, for example.
And I mean from your perspective then,
I mean it's an expert in really studying
the emotional lives of adolescents in
the sort of neural bases.
Why have you found this
group such a particularly
interesting population to work
with?
Yeah, that's a really interesting
question because, um, as you know,
I'm not a developmental psychologist.
In other words,
I didn't enter into psychology
wanting to, um, you know,
pick apart aspects of human
development. Um, but I've gotten really,
really interested in adolescents even
in the last five years because they
offered a really unique tool or really
unique sort of lens to understand basic
emotion.
So what I mean by that is that adolescents
really is a time where we see a lot
of changes in the way that
people experience emotion, um,
both in their daily lives as well
as things we invoke in the lab. Um,
so adolescence is a
period of life that is,
it's sort of characterized by
emotions that are, um, not, uh,
that are similar sort of qualitatively
to other periods of the lifespan,
but they might be sort of dialed
up in their extremity. So the, um,
adolescents tend to
experience more frequent,
both positive and negative emotions.
And when they experienced them,
they tend to experience them as sort of
heightened as date of a, of extremity.
And this is also a period of life where,
um,
there tends to be a common
onset of psychopathology.
So relative to childhood
as well as adulthood. Um,
mood and anxiety disorders in particular
tend to emerge during adolescence, um,
in their sort of initial onset. So, um,
the way I think of adolescence is a
really unique period of their lives and
where we can track a couple of things.
One is these common and typical changes
in the way that emotions are experienced
and then we can relate them to ways
in which the brain may be behaving or
functioning uniquely
during this time of life.
And so this can tell us both about sort
of basic aspects that link emotional
experiences to a brain
functioning as well as sort of,
um,
give us a lens to really zoom in on this
really particularly interesting period
of life.
It's fascinating. And not only are
you studying emotions, you know,
in sort of healthy adolescents,
but your work has also explored really
important clinical implications.
For one emotion goes awry
with the focus on anxiety.
And I wondered if you could just elaborate
a bit on how your brain imaging work
on anxiety can help us understand,
you know, emotion more generally.
Sure. Um, yeah,
this is you're referring to is work
that I really got interested in doing
graduate school. Um, and based on
reading a great deal about, um, you know,
the brain and neuro basis of emotion.
One thing that I noticed was that most
of the studies that study emotion in the
lab tend to use him a procedure where
emotions would be evoked using some sort
of Q and the environment.
And then we would measure sort of
brief response to that cue. Um,
but we know that in our everyday
lives and in the real world,
emotions don't necessarily play
out over these very brief, uh,
sort of reactive timescales.
And so what we wanted to do, um,
in this work was to try and provide new
tools and new ways to try and understand
how emotion might be maintained over time.
And this would be sort of
trying to understand how
sustained emotion may be sort
of held on to,
if you will by circuitry of the brain.
And with this work we actually identified
some interesting distinctions between
the brain circuitry is that can sort
of evoke in eScience significance to
emotional cues, um, relative to those
that actually remain persistently active,
that could hold on to let's
see, an anxious state for
minutes at a time. And so,
um, one of the things I think
is cool about this work is
that it might provide us
new avenues to try and understand
maintenance in the lab,
which is not a simple thing to do,
but it may have relevance to a number
of different sort of clinical disorders
that aren't particularly those that are
marked by sort of hyper arousal that
maintains over time or
disorders of rumination where
I'm worrying or other kinds
of mood states might be maintained over
time. And so we're hoping through, um,
future studies and some current studies
that I'm working on to apply these ideas
to try and ask the question of whether
these sustained emotion systems may in
fact also have a prominent role in the
pathophysiology of anxiety disorders.
And do you think from this,
I mean that's just such interesting work.
Do you think there might be particular
implications for understanding anxiety
and adolescents that's unique
or different from adults?
Yes. Um, I think so.
So one of the interesting features of the
emergence of anxiety disorders is that
certain anxiety disorders based
on epidemiological work, um,
tend to emerge relatively
early in the lifespan.
And these are have sometimes been
referred to as fear disorders.
That is those that are marked by extreme
reactions to some sort of environmental
cue.
Um,
but disorders of the anxiety disorders
that are more characterized by these sort
of lengthy states of rumination or worry,
um,
tend to initially present themselves
during the adolescent years.
And so one thing we're testing right now
is whether brained properties of brain
development in the circuitries that I
sort of mentioned earlier may in fact be
distinct.
And potentially sped up in path and in
I'm anxious adolescents who tend to have
this sort of worry like profile.
And this is something that we are
examining right now through some clinical
studies with some collaborators that
I have in New York. So stay tuned.
Very exciting.
I can't wait to hear.
So then,
you know,
as you're thinking about the work that
you've been doing and what got you first
hooked into the study of emotion,
when you sort of like look
forward into the future,
where do you see the field headed?
I think that, um, even
in the last 10 years, um,
I'm trying to understand that sort of
neural bases and underpinnings of our
emotional experiences has
really transformed. I mean,
this is a field that's rapidly evolving
and I think we're getting a better and
better handle on some of these basic
functional aspects of different circuitry
in the brain that may mediate,
um,
emotional experiences and
regulation of emotion. Um,
I think what a lot of people are working
towards now is to try and use that
information to help inform,
um,
sources of risk as well as sources
of resilience. For psychopathology.
So to try to translate this,
these basic findings into a more
sort of clinically relevant way,
clinically relevant contexts,
which may in fact help us to, um,
say something really important about the
sources of, um, sources, variability,
sources of risk and resilience
I relevant to psychopathology.
And so when you talk then to students who
are asking you not only where the face
of the future headed,
that,
what advice would you have for them as
they think about embarking into this
field? What, what sorts of
things do you say to them?
What do you think are sort of important
kernels of wisdom to take is as someone
thinks about getting into
this field and getting hooked?
Um, so I think that one important
thing to consider is that
being an active participant in
working in research laboratories,
I really provides insight into how
emotion an emotion research works that you
can't really get from a textbook or
from a sitting in a classroom. And I,
so I would encourage people who might
think that they're interested in this
field to really get their feet wet and
try out a number of different experiences
working in laboratory setting
and potentially working
in a broad array of them
to really try and hone in on
to the particular interest
areas that you have. Um,
the other thing I would mention is that,
um,
although we don't hear about it as
much these days, um, some of the,
the very classic and really fundamental
things we understand about emotions have
in fact been derived through the use
of animal models. And I think that, um,
as a student I was really encouraged to
do a lot of reading on these very basic
and fundamental findings that may
diverge from sort of a human emotional
experiences,
but really provided the basis
and foundation upon which
the field of emotion has
been able to build into the studying,
you know,
all the way up to human
emotion in psychopathology.
So I would also encourage students
to really go back in time and,
um,
and read and really make sense of some
of these very fundamental findings that
have shaped the field.
Great. Thank you so much for
speaking with us today, Leah.
It was great to talk to you.
Thank you.
It was fine.
Thanks. And this concludes our experts
and emotion interview with Doctor Leah
Summerville from Harvard University.